a new era in American spaceflight
starting just before sunrise on
Florida's Space Coast a SpaceX rocket
equipped with the first commercially
developed crew capsule began a critical
test this morning when it blasted off
toward the International Space Station
there was no one on board but that
capsule could be used to take astronauts
into space later this year
mark Strassmann was there for the launch
he joins us now from the Kennedy Space
Center wow this is some exciting thing
to happen what it could happen what it
could mean for for all the rest of us
good morning I got to tell you right
around three o'clock this morning the
skies were on here just lit up along
with the moods of thousands of people
who had gathered here to watch this
launch this moment represents the
beginning of a new space age in which
companies rather than countries will
lead the way to what here liftoff the
Falcon 9 rocket and his crew Dragon
capsule soared into history this morning
bringing America a giant leap closer to
completely homegrown space travel for
the first time in nearly eight years ten
minutes after launch the Falcon 9 rocket
stage successfully touched down on a
recovery ship 300 miles off the Florida
coast by then the crew Dragon capsule
was already orbiting earth at five miles
per second SpaceX founder Elon Musk a
little emotionally exhausted because
super stressful but it worked so far
through next Friday the crew dragon
needs to prove it can safely dock and
undock autonomously with a space station
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere and
splashdown off the Florida coast if all
goes well the SpaceX capsule could carry
two astronauts as early as this summer I
want to be clear our goal here is safety
NASA Administrator Jim bridenstine told
us NASA is no longer in the space race
business it is less relevant as far as
the date what is more relevant is the
safety of our crew so we're gonna make
sure we do things right period end of
story on this mission the only passenger
is a dummy a smart dummy named Ripley
outfitted with sensors to measure the
impact of the ride for its eventual
first fliers NASA astronauts Bob Behnken
and Doug Hurley so far so good so from
our standpoint this is this is what you
want to see you want to see the team
hitting its stride seeing a success like
this definitely gives us a lot of
confidence in the future just before
daybreak tomorrow morning the crew
dragon will dock with the International
Space Station at NASA and SpaceX just
have to hope that docking is as
picture-perfect as this morning's launch
Dana mark thank you for those of us that
remember the space shuttle or the Apollo
launches and gathering around the TV it
is really exciting to see this again